NAME THAT FOREIGN RAP.
>> THANKS TO YOUTUBE WE CAN NOW
SEE TERRIBLE RAP VIDEOS FROM
EVERY COUNTRY ON EARTH. THE
WORLD IS OUR FUNKY BUNCH.
I AM GOING TO SHOW YOU GUYS A
WEIRD FOREIGN RAP VIDEO THAT WE
FOUND ON YOUTUBE AND FOR 250
POINTS YOU HAVE TO BUZZ IN AND
NAME THIS SONG IN ENGLISH.
ALL RIGHT, FIRST ONE: HERE IS A
GUY FROM JAPAN.
>> Chris: SCOTT.
>> EMINEM-SG?
>> Chris: YES, POINTS.
JACKIE 2 CHANZ
>> Chris: GOOD ONE.
POINTS.
>> NEXT ONE: LOOK AT THIS FINE,
FINE SERBIAN CITIZEN.
>> YES, SCOTT.
>> UKRAINE IN THE MEMBRANE.
>> Chris: YES.
WELL DONE.
>> MC CELLPHONE KIOSK.
>> I HOOK YOU UP.
I HOOK YOU UP.
I HOOK YOU UP WITH GUN AND DICK.
WHICH ONE YOU WANT? YOU WANT
GUN OR DICK?
YOU WANT BOTH?
>> PS, GUN IS ALSO DICK.
>> Chris: THIS NEXT GUY
ROCKING THE MIC IN AUSTRIA
..
>> AUSTRIA GOT SO MUCH SOUL.
JAMES.
>> NAZI BY NATURE.
>> Chris: I AM GIVING YOU A
STANDING OVATION OF POINTS.
AND LOOK AT THIS NAUGHTY
SLOVAKIAN BRO.
>> Chris: JAMES.
>> CZECH YOURSELF BEFORE YOU
SLOVAK YOURSELF.